what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and we have only a
couple of more days until we get the
next episode
episode six of wanda vision and although
we may have gotten some answers to some
of our questions in regards to one
division we still have
a lot more questions about what exactly
is going on but one thing that i have
specifically been wondering about
is ultron and spoiler warning if you
haven't seen
wanda vision episodes five essentially
there are going to be some spoilers in
this video
everyone was pretty mad that ultron was
only in one movie he is a huge
villain in the marvel universe one of
the biggest ones and he got killed off
in just one film
or did he what if ultron never died and
has secretly been plotting his revenge
against the avengers and more
specifically
wanda who betrayed him and basically
defeated him in avengers age of ultron
does marvel have more plans for
ultron it appears that they very well
could i don't think we've seen the end
of ultron because in the comics he
always pops back up periodically it's
basically impossible to kill him because
ultron isn't a person
he's a.i he lives digitally so why would
it not be the same
in the marvel cinematic universe well
since before wanda vision even premiered
there have been a lot of rumors stating
that ultron could be returning in one
division
and now ultron's name has been dropped
two times throughout one division now
obviously ultron
has a very big connection to wanda since
age of ultron
her and her brother patria were
basically on his side until ultimately
betraying him and defeating him but
ultron is a big part of her past and
they've been showing us
wanda's past and these weird commercials
all throughout one division they've
talked about hydra a couple of times and
they've talked about lagos where she
accidentally killed a bunch of people
and i don't think we've seen the end of
flashbacks to wanda's past yet
and i think ultron is going to make
another appearance in the marvel
cinematic universe and here are three
very realistic ways that he could return
to the mcu and i think the third one
is actually truly happening in one
division but we'll start with number one
and that is he is born
into a new reality the one that wanda
has created
if this happens he could return in this
new reality in one of two ways
the first part is that he could simply
just appear as a mere part of this weird
reality
an illusion maybe maybe he could be
conjured up by mephista or nightmare if
they are the ones who
are truly controlling this reality and
this would be especially true if it's
nightmare
because nightmare feeds off of fear and
ultron is the reason that her brother
pedro
died and if nightmare is the villain it
would make sense that ultron returns to
her in the form of one of her greatest
fears
in this weird reality now this first way
means that he could only exist in this
reality but the second part is that he's
created in this reality but he actually
goes back
into the real reality this is something
that happened in the comics wanda
revived some people in one reality and
when that reality got broken down
they actually appeared in the main
reality still alive
wanda has already proved that she can
create things in this new reality we
have her two twin boys
this actually threw off jimmy wu because
he didn't think that she could actually
create things he thought that wanda
could only control things that were
already there
so it's clear that things can be created
in this reality and as far as the twins
are concerned it's already been stated
that we have not seen the end of them
this implies that they also can create
this reality that is created by wanda
and if they can escape we can assume
that a
created ultron in this reality could
escape as well
so that's one way that ultron could
return the second way that he could
return
is through hydra aim they could bring
him back
now we haven't exactly figured out what
all these hexagons mean they could very
well be aim
nothing is really certain at this point
but it appears that hydra has already
played a significant role
in one division with their callbacks and
of course hydra are the ones that
experimented on wanda and pietro and
gave them their powers
now as we've learned if you cut off one
head of hydra
three more grow back so it would be kind
of foolish for us to think that
hydra is actually gone but we know that
hydra played a big part in ultron and
wanda's life the connection is there and
aim is also apparently going to play
some part in the mcu moving forward
maybe not in one division but definitely
an ant-man and the wasp so them showing
up in one division isn't out of the
picture
and what if hydra and or aim thinks they
can bring back
ultron and use him as a weapon it's kind
of the perfect plan
if they can do it successfully and this
is something that aim
and hydra would try to do and i actually
think that director tyler hayward could
be a part of it
especially after he showed the footage
of wanda breaking into a sword facility
and taking vision's body he seemed to be
quite upset about that and i think
that's because he actually has his own
plans for vision
hayward could want him back because
they're actually trying to bring back
ultron
it's very clear by the footage that we
saw that hayward himself showed to sword
that vision was being experimented on
they had dismembered all parts of his
body connected to his torso his legs his
arm his head and there were a bunch of
scientists in the room
and as we know vision was actually
supposed to be ultron originally
then you have to take into the fact that
sword is now making
weapons this was noted in one division
episode 4 when monaco rambo
talked about making weapons not to
mention sword used to stand for
sentient world observation and response
department and now
in the mcu it stands for sentient weapon
observation and response department so
it's very clear that sword is trying to
make
weapons and what better weapon to have
than ultron
if they can control him in which good
luck because tony stark thought he could
and he was wrong on that one
initially at least so that's the second
way that he could come back
sword recreates him or maybe tyler
hayward is secretly working for hydra
and it's hydra that's going to recreate
him that facility could have very well
been a hydra facility because many of
the members of sword were very shocked
to see the footage
but the third way that he could come
back is that he was actually never dead
ultron never left he's ai artificial
intelligence he
is in the internet you can't really get
rid of him we already saw him transfer
his consciousness
into other robots in age of ultron it
was super
seamless for him he doesn't really seem
to have a base robot or mainframe that
everything
operates from for him it's very fluid
there isn't an absolute ultron he exists
digitally and it may not be that hard
for him to return
especially if there's going to be new ai
stark iron legion bots going around
which there probably are considering the
fact that we're going to get armor wars
which is about what happens when stark
technology iron suits
fall into the wrong hands this could
also be a hint that ultron may not be
done
and in fact could have never been done
but could have been plotting his revenge
against the avengers the entire time
now as we know he hated stark the most
but unfortunately tony stark is dead
and the next people he probably hates
the most after stark are probably vision
wanda and pietro well pietro's dead and
vision is dead
kind of maybe we'll see what happens but
wanda is alive and if ultron has still
been around this entire time he could
have been watching and waiting for the
perfect opportunity to strike
and perhaps that opportunity could be
seizing control over vision's body
now when vision was alive there's no way
this could happen because vision
wouldn't let it happen but now vision is
dead and when
sword had a hold of him he seemed to be
connected to some type of hardware which
means he could be connected to the
internet
which means that ultron could definitely
figure out a way to get
inside a vision and perhaps take over
him now when sword had him and had him
dissembled that probably wouldn't do too
good for ultron it would still be pretty
hard to put himself back together but
now
vision is put back together and although
we don't really know yet
vision really hasn't been himself so
perhaps ultron may get his
opportunity sometime soon but those are
the three ways that i think
ultron could come back and i think he
will come back it's only a matter of
time but let me know what you think in
the comments down below
if you love marvel love theories and
want to stay up to date on the latest
mcu news be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me